i'm joined now by rachel and bryan
season 13 of the bachelorette most
notably
the first black bachelorette in the
show's history also joined by
lindsey vonn olympic gold medalist and
pk star defenseman
for the new jersey devils star
defenseman's pushing it pk's been
terrible last little while but
carry on as a black man do you
feel betrayed when you see a black woman
with a white man and i might not
necessarily say i feel betrayed
but i feel some type of way rachel you
and i we go back
and so uh what you mean what was that
what you mean what happened i'm just
kidding don't get no i just sounded like
like
you and i we go back and she looks like
he looks at the husband yeah we do
choo choo the way he said it it sounded
like he was implying something
yeah i'm gonna tell you something that i
haven't told you yeah before
2017 i'm watching the bachelorette and i
see finally they chose a black woman
they chose a black queen and i'm
thinking to myself
shirley surely she's going to pick a
black king
i know nothing about brian like nothing
about where i never met the guy
but all i see is rachel picked a guy who
is seemingly white
um i felt some type of way about that
what would you say to someone
who shared those sentiments what would
you say to them
well friend well friend mind your
goddamn business
and why are you watching the
bachelorette okay bye
she said friend was just like to be
clear like we never hooked up
that's what it felt like i felt like she
was just trying to be like yeah nothing
happened
okay friend because we're friends right
friends i don't even know if i should
say friend after you just said that
no i'm kidding but honestly i had to say
you know what my journey of love can't
be any different just because the color
of my skin is
and people can't judge me for picking
someone who doesn't look like me
have you lost friends based on who you
love
being a black man
i wouldn't say i've lost friends i've
created
there has been a lot of difficult
moments with people that i'm very close
to
that haven't it's been very
hurtful and i don't know exactly how to
approach it
i wonder if he feels the same way about
her being with him that he does about
the black dude being with the white
woman
right like it's interesting to me that
this topic is kind of like i felt
betrayed when i was like
but i never hear i never get black dudes
getting mad about
black men be with white women no but i
hear i hear this rhetoric
i seen black i've heard that that
hypocrisy where
black guys are like yo look at this
black look at this black girl going out
with his wife why are you
why is he why is she with this white
dude i'm like brother you date white
chicks why is the difference when
is she when it's another person it's not
the same thing you know i mean
it's not the same thing i've heard that
i'm like man whatever
i don't know how to get rid of racism
and just allow them to see him for the
person that he is
i don't know how to do that and that is
that is why i want to
talk because i
no i i love i love i'm going to tell you
something i love every
moment of it why because it what this
promotes
is growth and strength in our
relationship
i know is this is this even funnier
because you know they got divorced
so this is that's why it's like
literally like a couple of months after
they got divorced so yeah no
we're getting stronger and stronger
they're like
when we're apart adversity is a great
thing when people show
true colors with every this world is
full a lot of people
not everybody's going to be accepting of
everything
is this shirt ripped underneath the
sleeve hey my shirt ripped
what you talking about see if i was like
see if i was like
yo this dude sure ripped
where are you sure when my shirt is
ripped it's like that girl it's like
when you say yo look that girl is
looking at it is going out with the
white dude but i'm going out with a
white woman you know what i mean my
shirt ripped
i got an email and it pierced my heart
she said
can you help me what can i do as a white
woman to be more accepted by black women
what would you say i don't know the
answer to that
i i feel like you know pk's family
and his friends his family's friends
everyone has been so
accepting of me and i just try to be
kind to every person that i meet
and even if they hate me because i'm
with a strong
black man i'm still the same person why
are you laughing
i don't know this whole video is just
awkward the music but that's what it is
that's what enter it uncomfortable uh
conversation with a black man
if you're uncomfortable i'm
uncomfortable not because it's poignant
or it's making me ask questions i just
feel like the setup is stupid
the questions aren't really good i feel
like
the tone of the music and just like the
awkwardness i'm just like
but you know what i'm only five minutes
in so maybe i'm missing it but just
i know that it doesn't make you sad it
does make me sad because
it actually not sad it makes me feel
extremely guilty
why because i am taking a strong black
man
away from them you see
you see what i'm talking about this is
see
this is cringe right but if that's how
that's how she feel she can feel how she
feel it's still cringy
yup and but i love him
and i i mean i shouldn't be penalized
for that i don't think
but there is the reality that that is
true
why should i have to think like that i
actually had
there was a a friend of mine um
and he actually later apologized for it
but he actually
when i was with lindsey i don't even
know if i told you no he didn't know um
but he broke me down about like dude you
need to be with like
a sister like you need to and i think he
had a couple drinks but
i never stopped him or put him in his
place i just let him speak
i just let him speak because i said you
know
this is a lack of education we also have
to be aware of what hate is
and what a lack of intelligence is it's
not just lack of intelligence it's not
just ignorance it's hurt
if i see if it's like like i said i said
this before when people talk and
whenever i got
i got the side eye or people just come
up to me like i'm in the bar
and girls come up to me and be talking
about
me and my relationship people i don't
even know yeah people do that
it's not just ignorance it's hurt
especially especially if it's a black
woman so i don't know i don't say it
because i understand the hurt
it's so i would add hurt in there not
just
it's not necessarily lack of education
or whatever it's they hurt and what
would you say to the black people
who have that ideology of kind of like
you're with you're
you're still with the traitor you're
with an enemy okay
so if i'm talking about i'm talking
about changing the game i'm talking
about changing the narrative
and all of us as a black culture are
talking about changing
well you can't want change in one ways
and not the other way
if we're talking about accepting people
for who they are and seeing people for
who they are
and loving people for who they are and
if somebody respects you respect them
back then
it shouldn't matter what color the pers
people are saying this is not about
black and white
this is a human rights issue he said
emmanuel
how can i love my black man my black
husband
better i'm going to ask you pk to answer
that question to lindsay
while also realizing you're answering it
to the world how can
a white woman love a black man better no
that was a question yeah you could shut
that off we're good
this was crazy it felt like it was a
discussion about interracial
relationships
but that was basically just centered
around the black man's experience and
their
point of view which is weird and they
didn't even go into like what are some
of the biases that some black men may
feel
or like just some of the extra layers it
was just like so tell us why you love
who you love
i was just like do you feel guilty about
loving who you love
when you are not with someone who thinks
you should be with someone like the type
of person you love like how do you feel
like
i was just very surface level i'm just
like blah how can i love the black
man better as a white woman
i'll go take an african studies class
like what do you want me to say this is
maybe you can give more said that this
is probably your department better than
mine
i just i thought it was so cringe but on
my side it's really
if you want to have an awkward like an
uncomfortable conversation about that
you have both sides you have to have the
size of the black women that do not
people that don't black women black men
that do not
believe in integration interracial
relationship and people that do and have
that conversation then
and that's gonna be very uncomfortable
and that's gonna be very you know
and we're gonna solve some things and
things you know i mean you're not gonna
if two people from the same side just
ask the questions yes you ask the
questions but
it was really like you said abby it was
really on the surface if you want to go
deep and really solve something and
really
explore this right now you just
advertise one side i want i still want
to see what's the reality
of the other side i don't believe in
interracial relationship
that's what i have that's who i want to
have a conversation with that's who i
want to trade it with brother the white
dude even speak
who did the white guy even speak what
what guy that's my whole point
apparently he's latino i don't even know
he's that so i would
not like to maybe hear what's that
experience like it's possible
you know what i mean like it was
centered if you think about it yeah
but maybe maybe he spoke about it but
that like they narrowed down because of
you know
attention span you don't want to try
still at the end of the day your product
is
if i want to have this conversation i
want to have all parties there and i
want to i want to be able to go back and
forth that's the way i have a
conversation yeah you know
i don't have a conversation with the
people that think like me and just
answer those questions
because to me that's a circle jerk
that's just you know
stroking my own ego and whatever or
answering my own questions
i want to have a conversation with the
other party that does not agree with me
and we could go back and forth i mean
even if you don't even do that just get
all the perspectives of the people who
are present
all i heard was about how lindsey vonn
feels
when she's dating a black man she felt
like she stole one from the community
which was super cringe or
all this other stuff and i'm just like
okay this is still centered around the
black man's experience of dating a white
woman
even when he asked the best questions it
was like why didn't you end up with a
black man
how do you feel about it and it wasn't
about what's it like in your
relationship especially what is the
cultural experience that you have and
dating into a latino like
it was just centered around what pk has
to do with yeah this could have gone so
deep what is it like to race interracial
kids their lived experience
right what is the identity stuff that
they face what about your parents or if
your parents are interracial what kind
of identity issues do you face
you know what's it like for for the
ladies talking to other black women when
they date outside
i would have liked to hear all those
different perspectives instead of just
centering it around like
pk why are you so free and happy who
cares we always hear that
you know so that's why i was just
getting like really bored of this
conversation and
you know where it goes like i feel like
i stole a black man man
anyways i was very surprised by how one
dimensional it was like didn't even
touch on the idea like
when people did outside their race they
often talk badly about black women i'm
like why does that exist that's a
dynamic you could have explored easily
you know pk have you heard this what are
your thoughts on that does that
influence you subconsciously there's a
whole bunch of ways you could have taken
this
conversation how long was that video 13
minutes okay and i took away nothing
i took way nothing well you know lindsay
feels bad
felt bad yeah because she dumped his ass
and you know you know
the problem is soft
all right those are my thoughts people
wanted us to watch this video and uh
i did and i thought it was terrible so
those are my thoughts
but maybe you guys disagree maybe you
agree maybe you don't even care highly
possible
um leave your comments below